mon père était bizarre il ya un mois il
m'a dit ta mère tu peux pas aller la
voir et
il m'a dit que ft fait taper
et sur le coup j'ai pas compris
salut c'est juliette et la fille que
vous venez de voir ses os ses habits
aujourd'hui je voulais vous raconter son
histoire et celle de tant d'autres
enfants qui témoignent au quotidien de
violence conjugale dans leur famille en
fait quand on parle de violence
conjugale j'ai l'impression qu'on oublie
souvent les enfants alors qu'en france
ils seraient environ 150 milles à vivre
dans des foyers où des violences ont été
signalées à les employés comprennent on
on comprend très bien on n'est pas
stupides on n'a pas là la distance on
n'a pas le côté la vision adulte de la
chose et moi je pense c'est pour ça
qu'on doit encore plus c'est qu'on n'a
pas le côté oui il faut restons sans
parce qu'il ya des économiquement par
rapport au but que les gens auront sur
nous non non moi juste que ca va pas et
puis c'est tout il ya quelques semaines
une de nos journaux gabriel à sortir un
documentaire sur notre plate forme brute
x qui racontait l'histoire d'une lady
une femme qui a survécu à des années de
violences conjugales la veille de mon
mariage
je reçois des coups quand je te dis des
coups sûrs tout mon corps c'est à dire
que quand je me déshabille je suis bleu
j'étais devenu s'approprie il m'a dit
maintenant tu parles tu t'es tu écoutes
sur notre compte tik tok on a mis
plusieurs extraits de ce documentaire
dont un de sa fille océane qui vous a
fait beaucoup réagir il y avait beaucoup
de questions sur la situation de cnp est
aussi beaucoup de témoignages du coup
j'ai décidé de relancer une messagerie
pour que les gens puissent me raconter
un peu plus value brute
aulas plusieurs d'années
a effectivement
documentaire à fond avec le pasteur
vraiment ils avaient l'intention de la
tuer des choses dont je me souviens plus
c'était en étant petit les explosions de
colère de mon père qui était
complètement imprévisible et d'une
extrême violence on comprend les
angoisses quotidiennes que peuvent ils
les enfants en situation de violence
conjugale de leur famille on a choisi de
donner complètement la parole à océane
pour qu'elle puisse vous raconter son
histoire en détail
je me souviens plus vraiment comment ma
mère et mon ex beau père se sont
rencontrés
j'étais beaucoup beaucoup plus jeune et
je faisais pas vraiment attention à ma
juste dit un jour que j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un et ça devait vraiment être
sérieux pour qu'elle me le présente
[Musique]
à la première fois que j'ai vu le
premier truc que je me suis dit c'est
qu'il était grand mais qu'il avait l'air
gentil et que ma mère a souri bout mon
premier souvenir de quand j'ai vu la
première fois c'est au parc juste à côté
tia maria pour un grand parc et on
s'était tous les trois réunis là et je
me souviens qu'il m'avait porté sur ses
épaules qu'on avait rigolé et qu'il
était super gentil
moment où j'ai commencé à avoir plus de
doutes par rapport à lui c'est bizarre
mais c'est flou en soi c'est que j'ai
pas de moment précis c'est juste que
quand j'y repense j'ai pas la notion du
temps sus car moi je me dis quand je les
entends parler ou surtout quand je
l'entends lui parlait que je dis bah
c'est bizarre normalement ça se passe
pas comme ça parce que moi j'ai pas
granger dans cette ambiance à moi
j'avais mes deux pans qui c'est mais
même si c'était plus ensemble
on les gaules s amusait j'ai juste y
avait pas de violence donc avec mon ex
beau père c'était les disputes
les insultes
tentative de contrôler quand ça marche
pas battre un ciel encore et encore il
écrit beaucoup beaucoup de cris la
première fin je me suis dit ça que ma
mère était une femme battue ça a dû
prendre du temps parce qu'il n'y avait
pas cette relation de wels était fragile
muette qu'à se laisser faire mais je me
souviens que j'étais chez ma grand mère
pendant une semaine je pense pendant les
vacances et elle m'a envoyé un sms qui
disait ne rentre pas sur le coup j'ai
pas compris mais mon père était bizarre
et je me souviens qu'il est rentré chez
ma grand mère il s'est assis à côté de
moi on a parlé néanmoins il m'a dit ta
mère tu peux pas aller la voir
au début j'ai pas compris
et
il m'a dit que st fait taper et sur le
coup j'ai pas compris donc j'ai réussi à
rentrer à la maison bout de quelques
jours même pas 1 ou 2 jours et a été
défigurée à laver la qui se fermaient
elle avait la mâchoire des mises
et elle avait des bleus
je les aie quand je les ai vus la fois
d'après parce que je pensais qu'on
verrait plus le même temps je suis pas
naïve donc je me doutais qu'on a à le
revoir
mais ma mère a est forte mon cas passe
au dessus des choses si elle est là si
elle arrive à pardonner l oubli et elle
passe mais moi je n'arrive pas
[Musique]
c'est juste attention au bruit en fait
aux types de bruits qui se passait et le
monde
le moindre coup boubrit je l'entendais
et georges arrêté de bouger pour voir si
il allait se passer quoi après et des
fois j'avais monté funk et allumé avec
le numéro des urgences au cas où
c'est devenu plus compliqué quand on
tirait un magicien on commence à grandir
parce que je voulais pas qu'ils soient
je voulais pas en fait qu'il soit
obnubilé par ça moi quand j'ai grandi
j'avais pas ça c'était pas tout rose
tout beau mais il n'y avait pas de
violence donc pour eux je voulais pas
qu'ils en aient et puis je savais que ça
allait leur faire peur donc quand ça
semeta a crié ou à taper contre les murs
je les prenais avec moi j'allais dans
leur chambre et je me mette à chanter et
danser pour que le bruit contre balance
[Musique]
alors ya une fois c'était pendant la
nuit j'avais cours le lendemain donc
j'étais énervé sous les fatiguer et donc
et je pense ma mère allaite oui mme
amara était enceinte à ce moment là
donc tout ça a fait que je me suis
énervé et j'avais un verre d'eau je fais
dans le salon et je vais jeter à la tête
sauf que bah c'est pas passé que il
s'est levé sachant qui fait quoi un
mètre 90 et qu'il a commencé à avancer
vite vers moi et je me souviens que ma
mère m'a littéralement poussé dans ma
chambre elle a fermé la porte et assez
mis devant la porte
donc je voyais plus qu'il se passait
mais j'entendais que ça a tapé contre la
porte fort et les hurlements jusqu'au
moment où il est parti mais j'ai pas osé
sortir de ma chambre
quand il y avait des très grosses
disputes il était pas là pendant un jour
peut-être deux et après ils revenaient
c'est comme si tout allait bien ils
faisaient des cadeaux ils étaient super
langis
dédoublement de la personnalité complexe
et ma mère passer outre à ce que le
parlement c'est important
la maman d'océane a eu trois enfants
avec son agresseur et c'est pour les
protéger eux qu'océane s'est préparée au
pire j'ai souvent eu peur de pas avoir
ma mère ouais j'ai même fait un plan
dans ma tête de ce qui commence à
comment je ferais si elle était plus
lent par rapport à eux par rapport à
comme moi commencent à s'organiser
qu'est ce que je ferais où j'irai c'est
que si jamais venait à mourir c'est
qu'il faudrait que j'ai la garde
exclusive des enfants donc avec maman on
en a parlé m'a dit faudrait que j'aille
voir son avocate j'avais prévu de faire
des cours à distance parce qu'on peut le
faire à la fac et de m'éloigner de paris
d'aller vers la banlieue pour pouvoir
leur prendre une maison un peu plus
grande pour pas qu'ils soient malheureux
en plus de la perte de la mer
honnêtement quand il se remettait en
sont ils séparés quand ils se remettent
ensemble
je faisais même plus de commentaires
sama
samassa m'a vidé ça m'a fatigué je
faisais plus attention c'est triste à
dire en jeu c'est horrible mais on est
on on est fatigué de faire des efforts à
essayer donc quoi on la laisse et je
sais que la dernière fois que ce sont
réellement séparés comme l'a dit je n'ai
pas cru je lui disais oui oui je pense
qu'elle savait que je la croyais pas et
ça a dû lui faire mal puisque j'avais
aucune j'étais persuadée qu'elle
n'arriverait jamais à sont détachés mais
là aussi
finalement après cinq longues années de
violence avec des plaintes déposées et
puis retiré lesdits la maman d'océane a
réussi à s'en sortir l'ancien beau
parent de seine a été condamné à six
mois de prison avec sursis alors
aujourd'hui - à la une ordonnance
restrictive par rapport à lui mais c'est
un bout de papier littéralement pour moi
c'est une vaste blague déjà faut la
renouveler constamment art que je vois
même pas l'intérêt de la renouveler
donc ouais on a une épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête
il faut savoir que bien souvent les
frais engagés en justice ne sont pas
remboursés et qu'il ya très peu de prise
en charge psychologique pour les
victimes directes ou indirectes
aujourd'hui sociale et sa maman lydie
vont bien mais il ya encore beaucoup de
familles qui vivent dans traumatismes
des violences conjugales
si vous ou l'un de vos proches est
victime de violences conjugales vous
pouvez appeler le 39 19 c'est un numéro
accessible 24 heures sur 24 si vous avez
trouvé ce reportage intéressant vous
pouvez vous abonner à notre chaîne brute
pour voir d'autres contenus similaires
et n'hésitez pas à m'en vais un message
sur instagram si vous avez des idées
d'autres sujets qui vous touche
[Musique]